from the makers of this movie of all
time comes the equally should be sequel
Twilight New Moon the continuation of
the epic romance between this one
hundred and nine year old shovel phase
and this pathetic codependent teenager
maybe I shouldn't be taking such an old
man it's gross
it really is gross witness their eternal
love for each other you're my only
reason to stay live that lasts a mere
five minutes before she's dumped for no
reason I don't want you you're just not
good for me
prompting his desperately obsessed
ex-girlfriend to mope around for months
on end so they could do this fancy shot
outside her window until fishface finds
a new man to latch on to a very very
shirtless man with an incredibly obvious
secret so your werewolf yeah it was only
in the movie to create a forced love
triangle for the franchise even though
they make it perfectly clear who dead
eyes will ultimately choose don't make
me choose this it'll be him it's always
been him
a role model so terrible and reckless
she'll encourage all angsty teenagers to
drive off on motorcycles with complete
strangers jump off cliffs slide
shirtless weird dudes are down stand
between vampires and large deadly
werewolf travel to foreign countries
without telling their parents and drown
themselves to see hallucinations of
their ex-boyfriends I'm pretty sure this
makes her a schizophrenic prepare
yourself for a movie filled with
placeholder dialogue that wasn't change
from the first draft
how about face punch do you guys want to
go see face punch face punch yeah I
remember the trio's like punch faces and
werewolves that rip out of their clothes
but always seem to get their shorts back
seriously do they keep stashes of jean
shorts hidden around the forest but when
shovel face is in danger of flashing
children just smelled poop face will
ignore the months of unnecessary turmoil
he's caused her and ride to save him on
an airline that enforces the abstinence
metaphor leading to a rush climax that
will leave me wondering who are these
random last-minute villains starring
more fake contacts
more ABB's
more of the actress who can't seem to
ever close her mouth
and even more staring
Twilight New Moon just watch True Blood
instead at least they get naked on that
show don't forget to watch this week's
screen junkies episode where dad's
answer Twilight trivia for their
daughters we made an eleven-year-old cry
and tell me something you'd like to hear
me say in my epic voice this is not a
democracy anymore That's So Raven Oh Oh
God not the bees not the bees oh they're
in my eyes my eyes the bees